sigo tan agradecido en la cama contigo
recorriendo tu ombligo si no somos
amigos y tampoco testigos
vamos no me puedo olvidar de la que me
dijo que siempre para siempre estaría
para m la que decía que solo una noche y
después nuevo má la que se fue con mis
ganas de amar mis ganas de vivir no la
HAS vuelto a encontrar demasiadas
mujeres
[Musique]
zone Europe sur
sensation bonsoir à tous et bienvenue
dans cette émission zone Europe sur
sensation en partenariat avec avec tv78
un numéro spécial réalisé à l'palmas de
grand Canaria en Espagne voici tout de
suite le sommaire ensoleillé de cette
émission diffuser la langue française et
les cultures francophones ce sont les
missions de l'Alliance Française
l'antenne de l'palmas accueille chaque
année plusieurs centaines d'étudiants de
la langue française à une meilleure
connaissance de l'Afrique nous
découvrirons aussi dans cette émission
La Casa Africa les îles Canaris vous le
verrez c'est un pont entre le continent
africain et l'Europe grand canalia est
une destination très gay friendendly
c'est at outre son climat la liberté la
tolérance et une vie nocturne vous allez
le voir très animé et puis nous vous
ferons découvrir aussi la la canalia la
lutte canarienne un sport dans lequel la
puissance se conjugue avec
[Musique]
habileté fr
à
los labioseran
soltarse ah en mismo cuarto no respirar
el mismo aire hoy voy a verte de nuevo
voy a envolverme en tu ropa susurrame en
tu Silencio cuando me veas llegar hoy
voy a verte de nuevo voy a alegrar tu
triste vamos hacer
unaa
am pero
no dis
las
[Musique]
sicuro on trouve en Espagne près de 5
millions et demi de francophones cela
veut dire que 12 % de la population
sa'est parlé plus ou moins français à
laspmas l'antenne de l'Alliance
française a été créée en 1926 cmion
diffusé la langue française et les
cultures francophones rencontrre avec
Fabienne lonois sa directrice zone
Europe Fabienne bonjour bonjour est-ce
qu'on peut dire que l'Alliance Française
ici à Las Palm c'est un peu le temple de
la langue française dans les îles
Canaries en général alors dans les îles
Canaries alors je vais peut-être aller
si loin parce que on est quand même sur
deux communautés donc il y a ten nous
donc sur cette partie là de la Palmas
oui après le temple j' aussi vous dire
que bien sûr l'alliance représente le
temple mais on est quand même assez
nombreux à à avoir bah à développer la
la culture française et c'est un bout de
France c'est un bout de France parce
qu'on essaie d'avoir justement des des
professeurs natifs on essaie de de
diffuser un peu la la culture française
avec les livres avec la bibliothèque
avec des films et cetera donc oui on
essaie quand même de d'être ici en
France oui votre première mission tout
de même c'est de de de faire apprendre
le le français d'enseigner le français
combien combien d'élèves vous avez ici à
l'alliance et et de de quel niveau
est-ce que quelqu'un qui n'y connaît
strictement rien en français qui ne
connaît même pas bonjour au revoir peut
venir ici ou alors on est on s'adresse
quand même à un public déjà avisé non
non non c'est pour tout le monde donc
ici effectivement on a une entre 250 et
300 élèves à l'année eu on a également
un centre d'examen qui est très
important c'est le seul centre d'examen
et puis on a tous les niveaux et euh en
général ce que j'ai vu ici c'est qu'en
Espagne les gens viennent déjà avec un
un petit niveau ils ont toujours eu
français à l'école quelque chose a
toujours un lien ouais mais on a quand
même des personnes qui viennent et qui
commencent de zéro donc on on a tous les
niveaux d'accord donc peu importe le
niveau comment comment le français plus
généralement est implanté ici peut-être
à grand Canaria c'est vrai que pour les
gens qui qui connaissent les Canaries
ont sûrement entendu parler anglais
allemand norvégien danois on sait qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens d'Europe du Nord
qui viennent au Canaris beaucoup moins
de français est-ce que néanmoins ça ça
intéresse les gens est-ce que le
français est bien implanté ouais alors
clairement il y a une volonté il y a eu
une volonté politique un moment parce
que le français enseigné dans les écoles
publiques en primaire à partir de ce
qu'ils appellent ici quinto sexto qui
est comme le CM1 CM2 et du coup et
obligatoire d'accord donc de toute façon
le français est quand même important
ensuite effectivement il y a d'autres
langues mais le pour le tourisme pour le
tourisme le français n'est pas autant
aussi important que que l'allemand ou
l'anglais évidemment mais apparemment
nous sommes en augmentation d'accord
donc les francophones sont de plus en
plus nombreux Suisses Belg français à
venir donc le français un bel avenir je
pense et pour pour peut-être donner
envie à certains de de parler français
quel argument pourrait-on donner pour
peut-être prendre des cours à l'alliance
ou tout simplement s'initier s'initier
au français même si en même si les îles
Canaries on si on regarde la distance
avec la France c'est pas tout proche non
c'est pas tout proche mais en même temps
il y a des vols il y a des vols quand
même dir direct pr oui oui on en est la
preuve ou effectivement alors le
français non c'est entre l'Espagne et la
France il y a quand même beaucoup de
d'échanges au niveau au niveau
commercial même et et au nveau
touristique ici il y a quand même un un
développement possible donc je sais
qu'on travaille déjà avec certains
hôtels et donc pour le travail il y a
quand même un débouché possible avec le
français ouais vous-même la demande vous
le disiez donc est en augmentation pour
pour l'Alliance ouais oui on a une
augmentation alors qui se précise sur
des choses accélérées en général les
gens veulent apprendre vite
veulent se certifier et beaucoup veulent
partir travailler en en Suisse en France
en Belgique ah d'accord c'est pas juste
pour rester beauou qui un projet
professionnel d'accord et partir à
l'étranger ouais ouou oui on travaille
aussi avec pas mal de de personnes qui
qui aimeraient partir travailler en
Suisse et en France en général d'accord
et le lien avec la Communauté française
ici il est est-ce qu'il est développé il
est important est-ce que les les
Français qui vivent à glan Canaria et à
Las Palmas
s'investissent sont tu as des liens avec
eux ou ou pas du tout finalement alors
j'ai eu quelques liens oui il y a il y a
un club de francophone en Grande Canarie
au grand en Grande Canarie oui et ils
font beaucoup d'activités en fait pour
pour justement que les les Français
francophones se réunissent autour de
choses comme des visites guidées des
balades et cetera c'est pas
nécessairement du français et aller
manger ensemble d'AC mais mais c'est
assez intéressant et donc je les ai
rencontré je ils sont venus faire une
conférence ici donc on a des liens
d'accord enfin vous êtes pas seul
alliance dans le dans l'écosystème
français non l'idée c'est justement de
de créer du lien alors moi justement
j'essaie de me rapprocher de ces gens-là
de de ce club mais également du lycée
français on a un lycée français on a la
chance d'avoir un lycée français
également les écoles qui sont bilingues
il une école bilingue pas loin en
français donc j'essaie moi de de toute
façon d'être le centre un peu de de
toute cette communauté française au
niveau pédagogique oui surtout au niveau
pédagogique pour moi évidemment pour
l'enseignement mais mais également pour
les Français qui viennent et qui qui
arrivent à l'alliance par hasard en me
demandant ben des conseils ouis
touristi juste pour pour terminer pour
pour revenir sur sur vos activités
évidemment l'apprentissage du du
français qui est l'élément centrale et
principal mais pas que on voit qu'il y a
une bibliothèque donc on peut venir ici
se documenter il y a aussi des des
événements culturels qui sont organisé
autant que faire se peut autant que
faire ce peut c'est la bonne expression
alors en fait oui on va l'idée c'est
d'avoir des bah la bibliothèque
effectivement de toute façon est à
disposition des étudiants évidemment du
public en général s'il prennent une une
carte de d'adhésion à l'alliance
également le cinéma alors oui nous avons
la chance de travailler comme comme
l'alliance travaille aussi en lien avec
l'Institut français avec le ministère
nous avons l'accès à une plateforme de
cinéma gratuitement comme Alliance
française et donc nous pouvons faire des
des fonctions gratuites et on va
commencer un cycle de ciné justement ici
à l'alliance et puis sinon nous allons
aussi avoir une exposition en accord
avec le CAM et la C à colonne d'accord
euh qui va qui va bientôt avoir lieu au
mois de décembre donc on commence à
avoir un peu plus de vie donc l'idée
c'est aussi de proposer des ateliers de
cuisin j'aimerais aussi faire des
ateliers sur le vin et cetera tout en
relation avec avec la culture française
donc on on va développer ça justement
cette année parce que bon la l'alliance
reprend tranquillement ses activités et
et là je vais essayer de développer tout
ça et on espère que cette interview cet
échange permettra aussi de de vous aider
dans dans vos missions oui j'espère
également merci beaucoup Fabienne pour
vos pour vos réponses merci
zone
Europe un peu plus de 100 km c'est
parare les îles Canaris du Maroc une
courte distance donc entre l'Europe et
l'Afrique qui n'est pas sans conséquence
sur les liens entre les deux territoires
pour en parler nous avons rendez-vous
maintenant avec andado
elle est journaliste et travaille au
sein de la Casa Africa un espace dédié
vous allez le voir au rapprochement
entre l'Espagne et
l'Afrique
Europe h bonjour bonjour comme je disais
avant maison Casa Africa ce lieu si
particulier a été créé pour favoriser
les les liens les les connexions les
interconnexions entre d'un côté le
continent africain les îles Canaries et
l'Espagne c'est comme ça c'est son but
son objectif c'est c'est de faire
cela oui le LET motif de la Casa Africa
c'est d'ailleurs ça Espagne Afrique
toujours plus proche ce que nous
essayons de faire c'est de favoriser les
contacts entre les deux territoires et
les connaissances mutuelles et ce à
travers tous les domaines l'art la
culture l'économie la géopolitique ou
encore les échanges
académiques les îes Canaries font partie
si l'on se place d'un point de vue
géographique du continent africain il
est donc
nécessaire et qu justement ques actions
vous menez vous au quotidien ici à
casarica pour rempliros missions j'ai vu
sur internet on a pu voir on voit sur
votre site que il y a plus de 200 évén
qui sont organisés chaque année c'est
c'est quelque chose tout de même
d'important oui et encore cette année
nous n'avons pas été particulièrement
actifs d'ordinaire nous organisons
chaque année entre 400 et 600 activités
l'an passé c'était près de 660
aujourd'hui par exemple nous avons eu
une réunion de femmes espagnol et
africaine qui travaillent dans le
secteur maritime et cet après-midi nous
aurons une représentation dans ce
classique et la diffusion
d'uncumentire nous venons également de
passer 4 jours à Madrid pour une
rencontre entre journalistes africains
espagnol et
européens en ce moment nous avons aussi
deux expositions ouverte au public l'une
sur le travail deque un artiste cap
berdien et une deuxième sur un projet
qui s'appelle enseigner
la
viotograotraola
ricalama ENF non seulement nous
organisons des événements ici au Canaris
mais aussi dans la péninsule ou sur le
continent africain quand nous avons la
possibilité de le
faire que ici il y a aussi on voit vous
le disiez des des expositions on voit
que la culture c'est quelque chose de
très importante que vous essayez de de
de favoriser pour créer des liens il y a
une médiathèque il y a un club de
lecture la la culture c'est un moyen
très efficace au-delà de l'économie la
politique pour créer du lien entre les
les deux continents parce que les font
partie de l'Europe et puis le continent
africain qui est juste en face à une
centaine de
kilomètres la culture est à mon avis le
meilleur moyen de rapprocher les gens au
sein de la Casa Africa nous travaillons
beaucoup grâce à des expositions du
théâtre de la danse ou de la musique ce
sont des activités qui plaisent beaucoup
au public qu à la littérature
CRE
[Musique]
nous avons un club de lecture auquel
participe une centaine de participants
et des centes de personnes qui se
connectent du monde entier Colombie Cuba
éateur et la péninsule
et per no solamente hacemos esoo que el
año pasado por ejemplo nos fuimos de
viaje culturaluiendo las Hu une fois par
mois nous lisons un livre d'un auteur
africain dont nous parlons et débattons
ensuite aussi nous essayons quand cela
est possible d'organiser des voyages
culturels l'an passé par exemple nous
avons été en Côte d'Ivoire et cette
année nous aimerons bien aller en
Guinée
Afri
Afric
PL
la notreè
est pas seulement puisque nous avons
aussi des ouvrages en français portugais
anglais arabe et en langues africaines
comme le
wolof cette médiiathèque n'est pas qu'un
lieu d'étude ou de recherche mais aussi
un espace où est organisé une multitude
d'activités il y a peu de temps nous
avons organisé un cours en ligne et en
présenciel de
wof para la sociedad
civil no s buscamos todas las maneras
posibles deercar la gente est-ce que
est-ce qu'on pourrait dire selon vous
qu'il y a au Canaris un peu un peu
d'Afrique une une part de de la vie
africaine du mode de style de vie de
africain qui qui existe et qui est
implanté ici au
Canaris en fait les premiers habitants
des îles Canaries venaient du nord de
l'Afrique il y a donc en chacun d'entre
nous une racine africaine et puis si
vous examinez le profil
de chacun des habitants de grand Canar
par exemple il y a beaucoup d'influence
d'Andalousie et du Sud du
saharaement et génétiquement nous sommes
donc
africains plus généralement la façon
dont nous gérons nos relations avec les
autres notre hospitalité notre culture
orale remble beaucoup à ce qui se fait
en
Afrique d'ailleurs quand des africains
viennent dans les îles Canaries ils se
sentent un peu comme chez eux même si
malheureusement il peut y avoir du
racisme
parfois est-ce que vous pensez qu'ici du
fait de ces liens là et de cette
histoire qui est enant liée entre les
les deux les deux territoires qu'il y a
moins de moins de clichés moins de moins
d'affaires de racisme moins de problèm
liés sur sur sur les populations
africaines
[Musique]
le racisme est inévitable en Europe mais
il est vrai qu'ici à l'mas surtout grâce
à l'activité du port et du tourisme nous
sommes habitués à avir des populations
différentes qui se
côtoi sur l'île il y a une communauté
mauritanienne importante mais aussi
marocaine ou sénégalaise il y a une
connexion avec le Japon l'Inde la Corée
du Sud l'Amérique du
Sud tous ces mélanges nous permett
d'avoir une sensibilité différente du
msage tout le monde a quelqu'un dans sa
famille ou une connaissance qui a vécu à
l'étranger ou qui vit et cela nous aide
à mieux saisir le sujet
migratoire nous comprenons pourquoi les
gens cherchent une vie
meilleure
de eso de tener una vida
mejorcicipesations la Casa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Afri
lo que yo diga y soy así así seguiré
nunca
cambiaréo que opinen los demás está ADS
quién
detiene
Palomas al
vuelo volando atras de
suelo mujer contra
mujer
defectos todo el mundo tiene dos
[Musique]
85 % des Français estiment que les
personnes gayes lesbiennes ou
bisexuelles devraient avoir les mêmes
droits que les personnes hétérosexuelles
les Espagnols sont quant à eux 91 % à le
penser alors l'homosexualité est-elle
plus facilement accepté en Espagne
reste-t-il des combats à mener pourquoi
grand Canaria est-elle devenue une
destination très prisé par la communauté
LGBT j'ai rendez-vous avec Jennifer
Molina pour évoquer toutes ces questions
elle travaille pour le collectif gamin
très impliqué sur le sujet depuis
presque 30 ans désormais ici zone
Europe tout d'abord Jennifer est-ce que
vous pourriez nous nous présenter le
collectif gamin et et son histoire ça
fait presque 30 ans je crois désormais
que vous vous existez pourquoi et dans
quel contexte l'association a éelle été
créée
ahamlec LGT de canaras un gamma est le
collectif LGBT des îles
Canaries le terme gamma signifie ça
suffit en langue aborigène l'association
a été créée en
1994 dans un contexte sociculturel et
sociopolitique où il n'y avait pas
d'espace pour les personnes
LGBT il nous a fallu donc lutter pour
obtenir nos droits comme tout le
monde des
persongtb ici au
can je pense qu'il faut prendre en
compte la situation dans laquelle nous
étions et où nous allons aujourd'hui
quand Gama a été créé il y a presque 30
ans maintenant il y avait déjà des
actions qui étaient
menées la première manifestation LGBT
s'est tenue par exemple à tenerif en
1978 pour autant nous étions dans un
territoire où il y avait beaucoup de
souffr concerne la diversité sexuelle il
existait encore à cette époque en
Espagne des lois qui punissaient
l'homosexualité à tefia sur l'île de
fernaventura il y avait un camp
d'enfernement pour les personnes LGBT
nous chabitons d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
avec des personnes qui ont été
emprisonnées pour leur orientation
sexuelle qui ont connu des persécutions
policières et qui sont aujourd'hui très
implic av beaucoup avancé que ce soit
aux îles Canar ou en Espagne nous avons
obtenu le mariage pour tous en 2005 la
première loi pour les droits des
transexuel en 2007 au Canaris nous avons
même notre propre législation sur le
sujet avec une première version en 2014
et une nouvelle loi votée en
2021 et plus récemment encore au niveau
national nous venons d'adopter cette
année une nouvelle loi pour l'égalité en
faveur des personnes LGBTI on peut dire
que nous avons fait beaucoup de progrès
nous avons de rénavant beaucoup plus de
visibilité davantage de défense de nos
droits un soutien social important ne
dire S
discrimin et quel type de situation
encore vous avez ici de d'homophobie
transphobie bipobie est-ce que vous avez
des exemples récents à ce propos claro
hay que tener en cuenta que que hay
ciertas situaciones discriminatorias que
no son delitos de odio
nous faons face aujourd'hui à des
discriminations qui ne sont pas considé
des
dél et d'autres qui le sont selon les
chiffres publiés récemment par le
ministère de l'Intérieur d'Espagne o
Canar le nombre de dél augmenté l'an
passé par rapport à l'année
prédente solo en la provincia Las Palmas
que incluye gran Canar fuerteaventura y
Lanzarote
au sein du collectif nous avons
l'impression qu'il y a une régression
dans la perception qu'on les gens des
droits des personnes LGBT surtout depuis
les débats qui ont lieu autour de la loi
sur
l'égalité nous observons une résistance
au niveau de la société mais aussi au
niveau politique avec des discours
fermes et régressifs de la part des
partis de droite et d'extrême droite il
y a des situations inquiétantes dans le
système éducatif sanitaire ou dans la
société plus généralement
hier par exemple on nous a retiré les
drapeaux qui sont à l'entrée de notre
local c'est un ge bien s
discatoire dans ce programme on aime
beaucoup parler de des sujets liés à
l'Union européenne on a
ici on a Eurobaromètre un sondage de la
commission européne qui dit que
l'Espagne est l'un des pays les plus
avancés sur le sujet des droits des
personnes LGBT 91 % des Espagnols disent
qu'ils doivent avoir les mêmes droits
que les personnes hétérosexuelles c'est
plus qu'en France 85 % Allemagne 88 %
Italie 68 % et Slovaquie 31 % qui est le
pire des pays est-ce que ça vous
surprend vous de voir que l'Espagne est
un pays si avancé d'un point de vue
euré non ça ne me surprend pas
finalement grâce au travail et aux
efforts des associations et collectifs
LGBTI en Espagne nous des avancé que ce
soit au niveau légal social ou tout
simplement pouvoir vivre sa vie de
manière libre je suis fier de vivre en
Espagne dans un pays où les personnes
LGBTI jouissent de leur espace même si
nous savons qu'il y a encore de
[Musique]
l'homophobie évment nous sommi cons de
ce qui se passe en Europe l'Italie par
exemple se trouve avec de tels sondages
aussi à cause du gouvernement de droite
et d'extrme droite P c'est pour cela que
l'on ne peut accepter qu'un tel
gouvernement arrive au pouvoir en
Espagne parce que cela s'accompagnera
nécessairement d'un
recul à l'Espagne c'est vrai que les
Canaris paraît être une terre d'accueil
pour les pour les personnes LGBT
pourquoi pourquoi les îles Canaries on
cette image et pourquoi les gens
viennent ici pour pour tout simplement
vivre leur vie comme ils l'entendent
[Musique]
les raisons ont permis can d'ê identif
comme une destination accueillante et
bienveillante pour les personnes LGBT
sont
variécoup tient d'AB à l'engagement et à
l'activisme et tout ce que nous av pour
que les can so respectueux de
chacun
can au niveau culturel également nous
avons agi pour reconnaître les
souffrances ont été enduré
ici laance
noususs l'UR nous permet quelque part de
nous construire loin des mauvaises
influences grâce à notre propre identité
canarienne
gigen enfin les î Canaries sont aussi un
refuge pour beaucoup de personnes obligé
de fuir leur pays du fait de leur
sexualité c'est quelque chose évidemment
que nous appuyons et que nous mettons en
avant dernière question est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer un peu comment
vous vous faites au quotidien pour aider
les gens qui en ont le besoin qu'est-ce
que vous faites des ateliers événements
on a pu noter sur le site internet que
1000 personnes avaient été pris en
charge par vos
soinsoutqueab collectif
objectif premièr nous agissons sur ce
con
à les niveau nous sommes NOTAM en charge
de la Marche des fiertés ici
àpm nous sommes aussi présents au niveau
politique pour faire en sorte que des
lois qui renforcent nos droits soient
adopté ensuite nous intervenons
directement auprès des personnes LGBT et
leur
environnement GAM dispose d'une équipe
de 10 personnes dédié à cela
tras de de
launos serv y
tambén nous pouvons offrir différents
services aux personnes qui ont le
besoin nous interene pour sensibiliser
par exemple les élèves nous formons des
professionnels dans l'éducation la santé
pour sensilis au sujet que nous traitons
et que les lieux dansquels il trava soi
des lieux SS pour les personnes
LGBT la preven distintos niveles
interven directao se dan Toa situes de
discrimin que reieren las personas t ESP
Yu et puis si les gensulent s'investir
il peuvent se rendre sur votre site
internet collectivo
gamma.com merci beaucoup Jennifer pour
pour vos réponses et pour toutes ces
informations concernant votre collectif
merci
beaucoup zone
Europe allez partons maintenant à la
découverte d'un sport traditionnel qui
nécessite plus d'habileté que de force
la lucha Canaria la lutte canarienne
pour l'emporter il faut réussir à
déséquilibré et faire tomber son
adversaire rien que sur l'île de grand
Canaria une quinzaine de clubs sont
recensés Hector Romero et le
vice-président du club de lucha de
guanatelm il m'attend pour une
présentation zone Europe
bonjour Hector tu es toi professeur de
de lutte canarienne est-ce que tu
pourrais nous dire qu'est-ce que c'est
la la lutte canarienne et en quoi ça
consiste oui en effet je suis entraîneur
j'ai commencé la lutte canarienne à 13
ans et j'ai aujourd'hui 40 ans cela fait
donc de nombreuses années que je
pratique ce sport la lutte canarienne
n'existe qu'au canaris et se caractérise
par sa noblesse bien que ce soit un
sport de contact et de lutte à la
différence du judo ou de la lutte
grco-romaine
il n'y a pas de catégorie selon le
poid c'est aussi un un sport historique
ça fait longtemps qu'on le pratique
aussi a Canar
oui la lutte canarienne nous vient des
Aborigènes il y a des livres des clichés
qui montrent très bien cela est-ce que
tu pourrais Hector nous expliquer un
petit peu ce que sont les les règles
basiques de la luten c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas forcément spécialiste en
France on connait pas très bien le sujet
est-ce que tu pourrais nous dire quelles
sont les règles
basiques objectif est de déséquilibrer
son adversaire pour qu'il touche le sol
avec une partie du corps qui ne soit pas
la plante des pieds dès que c'est le cas
le lutteur qui a fait tomber son
adversaire marque un point pour son
équipe c'est très différent làdessus du
du judo parce que si je comprends bien à
partir du moment où une partie du corps
touche le sol au-delà de des pieds bien
sûr on perd son son
combat princip différence oui c'est une
différence importante avec le judo où
peut marquer des points grâce à des
prises sans gagner le
combat au judo on peut aussi rester au
sol pour bloquer son adversaire ou le
mettre sur le dos dans la lutte
canarienne on doit rester debout et dès
qu'une partie du corps touche le sol on
perd son
combat comment se déroule une saison
classique de de lut canarienne il y a
des combats chaque fin de semaine
comment comment se déroule une saison
classique de
luten SP nous avons d'abord une
préssaison aujourd'hui par exemple nous
organisons une rencontre amicale pour
présenter nos équipes et notamment nos
meilleurs lutteurs à notre
publ ensuite nous aurons un championnat
composé de plusieurs phases il y a trois
tournois une ligue locale une coupe
locale une ligue régionale pour les
meilleures
équipes à la fin c'est un peu comme la
Ligue des Champions pour le
football et ici on a on a des champions
de lutte canarienne NST
club oui nous avons très bon lutteur qui
vient de nous rejoindre depuis tenerif
j'espère qu'avec lui nous obtiendrons de
bons résultats et que nous pourrons
remporter la Ligue cette saison comme
nous l'avons déjà fait par le
passé si je dis pas de bê il y a 17
clubs sur l'île de Grande Canarie est-ce
que c'est difficile de maintenir un peu
cet esprit très typique de la lutte
canarienne de pous jeunes à s'engager à
faire la lutte
canarienne oui en effet nous avons sur
l'île de Grande Canaria 17 clubs de
lutte canarienne et il est vrai qu'il
est difficile de pousser les jeunes à
s'engager dans ce sport parce que nous
faisons face à la concurrence du foot
bien sûr mais aussi du basket du judo de
la boxe notre sport est un peu moins
visible et nous essayons d'attirer comme
on peut les
jeunes aujourd'hui on a pas mal de
filles alors que historiquement c'est un
sport masculin notre club a aussi
toujours été connu pour être un VI de
Tal est-ce que tu peux nous dire aussi
si ce sport là la lut canarien est un
peu victime de de clichés et qui font
que bah les gens ne s'inscrivent pas
parce qu'ils estiment que c'est un sport
de brut et qui manque un peu peut-être
de de complexité ou
[Applaudissements]
autre l'une des caractéristiques de ce
sport est lié au
poids ici nous avons des lutteurs qui
pèse plus que d'autres et c'est vrai que
c'est un avantage par rapport à d'autres
sports de contact
tout le monde peut s'affronter la devise
principale de la lutte canarienne c'est
le grand a perdu le petit a gagn et
c'est vrai aussi que des enfants qui
n'entrent pas dans les cases de taille
ou de poids dans d'autres sports peuvent
trouver leur place dans la lutte
canarienne dans la lutte canarienne il
n'y a pas de discrimination selon la
taille ou le poids comme dans d'autres
sports nos portes sont ouvertes à toutes
et à tous
cioupor puisainant va va profiter un VO
que lu aques
démonstrationci Graci preupar la
Canar
[Musique]
ver hasta la
cumbreo nadie
[Musique]
te
Canario con
[Musique]
fuer siempre
droun
ferteonaio
Ramon lu Canaria con
fuerza
hayev al
estudiante
siempre nunca
[Musique]
F nunc
Go y
mir una
[Musique]
burro por
cadera VI con el
AR y te
Tiran una
Burra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
por
[Musique]
Cera mano
alaldaio zone vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en podcast audio et vidéo
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation et aussi sur tv78 à très
bientôt et bonne
soirée zone Europe sur
sensation